let's say your goal is to to be widely
known and to impact people's lives with
your music you can visualize it oh by
the way when you visualize a goal that
you want to achieve it's not in the
future this is to do with manifesting
when you want to manifest something it
doesn't work very well when you think I
will be famous I need to be famous I
want to be famous not good for
manifestation if you want to manifest
something you have to start with the
foundation for manifestation is always
the present moment it's not the future
it works very simply Jesus explained it
in one sentence just one sentence
whenever you pray for something believe
that you have received it and it will be
given to you now the key is that he did
not say believe that you will receive it
because that puts it into the future hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit I'm
a business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
some powerful ways to create your own
reality
Joy
he said when you pray for something in
other words when you want something
believe that you have received it now
what does that mean
you have to feel
In This Moment the fullness of life that
is there when you go deep enough into
the being of you then you feel there's
the fullness of life and you feel
there is a sense of Joyful aliveness
that there's a sense of power in you
that you sense it that is the presence
in you is there is a power in that
presence and that power is
there's a something that you could solve
almost there's a fullness in it already
you can't really once you contact you
when you're in touch with the presence
everything else that you could achieve
in this life I compared I have this
comparison analogy or whatever it is
uh that which you realize within you
this the power
is the cream
and everything else that you could
achieve in this world is the skimmed
milk
so the the fullness of life this is an
expression that Jesus used
he said and these are all gone together
he said I want you to have the fullness
of life
in some other translations he says I
want you to have to have Abundant Life
of now abundant does not mean lots of
things
because that would mean that shopping
malls are the kingdom of heaven
so the
Abundant Life does not mean abundance as
many things that abundance is it the
deeper place of a sense of of intense
aliveness the fullness of life that you
feel within you that is Abundant Life
presence to feel the life that you are
the Consciousness that you are out of
that everything comes that's the
fullness of life or Abundant Life You
Feel It In This Moment
and then if you then want to achieve
something you bring a vision what you
want and to let it merge with that
feeling
let's say you want you're a great
musician that's reaching who's reaching
millions of people and you see yourself
as this great musician reaching millions
of people but not in the future how does
this Great musician feel once he is
reached or she has raised millions of
people this is exactly how it feels
the fullness of life
you feel it right here now you merge the
vision with the feeling of fullness of
life which is presence
and then that's manifestation way number
two is embrace your own power with Greg
Braden when it comes to an affirmation
uh affirmations can be powerful uh
and for some people they're not and a
lot of people say well you know if the
the affirmation is so powerful how come
I'm not experiencing the effect
the what scientists tell us is the
average human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day
some of those thoughts are the words to
the songs and they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that create stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I say I'm about a
million times a day I said did they work
for he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times that we have
lost our power and that we have no
ability to communicate with a greater
power with god with the forces around us
and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted from
the texts leaving us with a sense that
we are essentially powerless beings and
if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you are a victim you need
a savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality so for
me it's it's a uh it's good news it's a
beautiful message of Hope and
possibility
as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in um I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited from the the religious texts in
the fourth Century by the church they
took they took out the information
helping us to understand that this this
deep relationship leaving us powerless
and and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
[Music]
well and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community uh as to whether or not I
would allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path
and when we began as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and it also give me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't way number
three is create your reality with Gabby
Bernstein and then the next question I
for you is when you're thinking about
manifestation and calling in new things
are some of you manic manifesting so
this is really important
are some of you those folks who are like
I've got the list I've got the vision
board I've said it a thousand times I
told all my friends I want him I know
exactly what he looks like and I feel
like he's with me and we're walking down
the street together holding him
you know who you who you are you know
who you are right you know exactly who
you are
look there's nothing wrong with being
clear
there's nothing wrong with being clear
but more importantly I want you to be
clear about how you want to feel and I
want you to just feel it
it's not about having the vision board
that's perfect it's not about having the
most amazing list you can do all that
work you can get clear you can be and if
anyone has a note of vision board it's a
beautiful board where you put all of
your images of what you want and plenty
of people spend a lot of time on that
board but they don't get into the energy
of what it feels like
and so they spend a lot of time with the
list they spend a lot of time with the
board and they spend a lot of time
talking about it but they don't assume
the energy of what it feels like to be
in that manifestation now
assuming the energy of what it felt like
to pop off all your tops really helped
me call in something that will help me
do it assuming that energy just brought
me into a state of being you are already
there sister you are already doing this
exactly as you are on your video blogs
in your lectures on Twitter and Facebook
you are already there and you want more
but you are already there
so acknowledging and accepting that I'm
already in the place that I am even
though I wanted to be more I am already
there
so if you want a romantic partner make
sure you have a real hot romance with
yourself
if you want more money
make sure you have a real good
relationship with the money you
currently have
if you want a new job make sure you have
a real good relationship with the job
you have today
everybody get that people think oh well
if I appreciate my job that I have now
then I'll only stay there no absolutely
not if you appreciate the job that you
have now then you show up to that job
with Grace
you show up back to that job with a good
attitude you show up that job with a
better approach you show up to that job
with more energy that job begins to
thank you that job says wait maybe
there's another job for you that job
then says here you're promoted here's
some more money have a great life
you create your reality your intentions
create your reality so if you are
constantly in a place of thinking I hate
this I hate this I hate this you are
serving that everybody's with me now I
know you are
so rather than focusing on that manic
manifesting first and foremost get
honest if you are one of them if you are
please raise your hands now manic
manifesters just get honest people get
your hands up
manic manifesters so you're reading the
books you're doing the work you think
you think you think but your energy
what's your energy like scream it to me
what's your energy like frantic
what was that
when you're saying when got it yes okay
what is your energy saying when your
energy is needy right it's controlling
it's manipulative
it's frightened
it's chaotic
what does that girl look like on a date
foreign
[Music]
so what is your energy doing how is your
manic manifesting affecting your genuine
manifestation
so I want you to get clear about that
and then the next piece here is just to
become super conscious and maybe you
take yourself for the next 30 days
where you can use that exercise in my
in-book where you put the little rubber
band around your wrist and you snap the
rubber band every time you catch
yourself talking about lack or you catch
yourself you know avoiding your finances
or you catch yourself eating the
hamburger or you catch yourself manic
manifesting just check yourself before
you wreck yourself
and [ __ ] and snap
your wrist right take that little
everybody got that you hear yourself
you're in the conversation with your
girlfriend and you're like oh my God I
can't get it I don't know what's going
on the man won't call me back I can't
kill myself oh my God and then all of a
sudden instead of continuing
snap the rubber band
I say I forgive myself
for my lack mentality I forgive myself
for my fear I choose to see this
differently
that's it
you don't need to figure out what to see
differently you just need to say I
choose to see this differently and you
will be given all you need to see
something differently also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there way number four is reprogram your
mind for abundance with Marissa peer and
for the last several years I've been
seeing more and more clients who come in
and the issue is that they have what I
call a money block they're not always
poor some of them earn a lot of money
but they seem to have the same problem
and that they just can't make enough
money to survive on and even if they are
making quite a good salary they can't
seem to keep money so they either say I
can't make money I don't know how to
make more money I don't know how to get
more money and I can't keep the money
I've got it seems to slip through my
fingers I ran out of week
and then I run out of money and what
that makes them feel is powerless and
helpless and also worthless
and as a therapist I know that I can
help them because
most money issues are actually not
solved by having more money and I know
that to be true because guess what
70 percent of lottery winners end up
completely broke so if you think you can
sell the money from with more money
here's proof that you can't if you
haven't got the right relationship with
money then having more money doesn't
solve it
so let me give you an example I worked
with a client for instance who was a
very successful professional and her
accountant said I don't understand why
you're not making more money you make
the same every year and you should be
making more she's I don't understand
either all my colleagues make more than
me but I'm kind of stuck in this money
time warp as it happened she was a
daughter of two doctors who certainly
weren't poor they divorced and she was
telling me in her therapy that her
mother would say every time she saw the
father ask your dad for money tell him
you need a coat tell your dad you need
shoes ask your dad for money for your
swimming lessons ask your dad for money
for the school because I was so
embarrassed because my mom had as much
money as my dad and she would never ask
him I had to ask him I said in the end I
just didn't ask him because I felt so
bad
that was interesting because he was her
problem she wouldn't invoice her client
so she didn't get paid she wouldn't put
her fees up so she was in this time walk
when it all went back in time to a
little girl who was horrified and
embarrassed and humiliated saying to her
dad dad can I have money for a coat I
need to go ask your mom then her mom
would say why didn't you get the money
for the coat
and because this played out in her life
here was a belief I just can't ask for
money I don't like to discuss you know
more no people who say I hate talking
about money oh I I don't like to discuss
money I can't ask for what I'm worth
when people owe me money I never say by
the way can I have it back and if you
don't ask people think oh they don't
need it they never ask for it they don't
care about money they haven't asked for
a pay rise so whatever is going on in
your childhood amazingly
will affect you and I know that too
because one of my graduates was saying
that every time she asked clients for
money and she put it away she couldn't
spend it she would get terrified she had
a memory of her mother had four jars
school clothes
bills food emergencies and when she
needed to get shoes her mother would
take the money out of the Bill's jar and
would cry and panic oh my God I don't
know where the money is coming from and
this often is what happens with clients
we learn what we live when you have
people who say money doesn't grow on
trees we haven't got the money I don't
know where to get the money from and I
have many many millionaires who worry
about money won't put on their heating
can't spend money because they too even
with all their money have a money block
so that's interesting but the good news
is that you can change it so with all my
clients with the girl who simply
couldn't ask for more with a girl who
couldn't spend the money she had and had
to hold it very tightly with a client
who wouldn't even put on his own Heating
what is so effective is going back and
having a look at how how did you get to
be this way so my little girl was little
and I said what do you want for
Christmas she said I'd like a palace and
a horse and a swimming pool and she
wasn't greedy small children have a
belief that everything is available and
when I said to you know Joan that's a
lot of money oh mama you don't buy it
the elves make it it's all completely
free
so children have a belief everything is
there there's enough to go around they
don't worry about the cost because they
haven't been programmed wired and
conditioned to we can't afford that that
costs money don't waste money so with
each of my clients uncovering What Lies
Beneath the money blocks was the thing
that transformed them first of all we
had a look at where did you get these
beliefs and then we removed them it's
like being a detective let's have a look
little detective work here
where we go and then it's like being a
dentist now we're going to extract them
get rid of them and leave you with a
belief there is enough money to go
around and
when you give something of value you can
be rewarded because the top 20 in every
classification in every field in every
area are never ever ever out of work
even in a recession and that's very good
news if you're a therapist
so what I do is I do give value I change
people in one session I do detective
like work to find out what's gone wrong
I do extraction to remove it I put them
back to where they should be I make them
themselves only better I change people
in one session I free them and I Empower
them that's really what I do I Empower
people and I set them free from all
their blocks with their money or sexual
or fear base now we all know people
who need help with money we all know
people who have these blocks and these
worries and these fear that it might run
out or that cost too much or I can't
afford it or what if I spend that money
and I don't get more and it's really
exciting and very very empowering to be
able to transform people using my method
rtt rapid
transformational therapy and the reason
it works is it is formulaic in that I've
designed a formula what I call the
formula for success and actually anybody
can do it many many of the people I
trained are going to be phenomenal
therapists have no therapy training
whatsoever no background in Psychology
no degree for instance we've trained
firemen and police officers and
beauticians to be phenomenal rtt
therapists if you would like to do what
I do if you would like to transform you
well after all we all want to change the
world but that's a big ass changing the
world how about changing people that's
how I do my bit if you change people you
are changing the world and it's fun it's
actually easy it's incredibly
transforming way number five is use the
power of meditation with Jack Canfield I
want to tell you why it's so important
to do this meditation he has proven
Journal articles proven with you know
researchers that when you do this
meditation seven days in a row the
immunoglobins if they take a swab of
your inside of your mouth they've
increased by 113 percent which is what
we want right now we want our immune
system to be stronger seven days of 20
minutes of meditation with a certain
form of meditation to increase your
immune system by 113 that's awesome and
when you're done the first time I did it
with him I felt like I was stoned I mean
I was like I was just literally like I'd
done some kind of you know hallucinogen
or something every cell in my body was
singing
and then when I came back with my eyes I
opened I felt so creative so calm so
peaceful so ready to take on anything
so just to boil this down really quickly
uh and again I really encourage you to
go and let him guide you through it on
YouTube but to give you a sense of it it
starts with tapping we all know you want
to tap on our on our what we call our
karate chop point and then tapping on
the top of the head and the eyebrow
Point side of the eye under the eye
under the nose
and the collarbone point which is a
collarbone and down about an inch and
over two and under the arm which is
about 10 10 centimeters down below the
arm and you can do that three times
while you just say you know I am totally
healthy everything's fine you know you
just say positive things to yourself
you're putting in a positive input as
you do that three times
and basically if you know tapping if you
don't you can just go to the internet
and you type in tapping diagram it'll
show you the points to tap on so you
would do that three times I'm not going
to leave the 20 minute meditation I'll
be just then you close your eyes
and you begin to focus on your breathing
and what you do with the heart math
breathing which basically creates a
coherence between your brain and your
heart which is what you want
you you breathe in for a count of six
like one two three four five six and you
exhale for a slow one two three four
five six and as you continue that six
count breath you imagine breathing in
through your heart
so even though the the amount in the
lungs how to say this even though the
air is coming in through your mouth and
your nose you're imagining it coming in
through your heart you're filling your
heart
and then as you exhale you imagine it
going out through your heart again and
you do that for several minutes and you
always focus on your tongue being very
relaxed on the bottom of your mouth
and you also then begin to as you do
that you focus on the you locate a space
in your hand
then you locate a space inside your left
hand so you're focusing on the sensation
of your hands your feet your legs your
torso but imagine the space inside of it
so it's kind of like it's Hollow in
there
and so you can go through your body
parts that way and then you imagine the
space behind your eyes
and a space between your eyes
so you're now creating mindfulness in
the present moment as you're using the
heart math breathing technique to
energize the Heart Center
and then you
begin to
imagine somebody that you love or
someplace that you love
and imagine sending energy to them
as a beam of light
surrounding them filling them protecting
them
and you can imagine a source of light
coming down from above like God energy
source energy infinite Intelligence
coming down in through the top of your
head down through your spine into your
heart and out through your heart to all
of those
places that person that place or thing
that you're sending that energy to
and then you do that for a little longer
than we do it now then you imagine
bringing that beam of light back into
your body
and now sending it to
the entire universe
so every cell of your body radiating out
this light to every every cell in the
universe
360 degrees
like the globe sending out energy
every cell in the universe being touched
by your light
and then you would draw that light back
into your body
[Music]
and then send it to every cell in your
body
so you see that light from your heart
going into your head your arms your legs
your torso your feet
until every cell of your body is filled
with this radiant light vibrating and
healthiness wholeness
understand
relaxed on your bottom of your mouth
inhaling for the count of six exhaling
for the count of six
and then again we won't do it now but
you would tap on those tapping points
again saying things like I am healthy I
am strong I'm stronger than any virus
I'm gonna be just fine you know Etc
and then again just focusing on your
breath
and then you would open your eyes and
come back into the outside world and
just focus on some object in your space
so you know you're back kind of
connected with physical reality
so that's the basic idea of it it's a
little longer than that
um if I see you're smiling so that's a
good sign yeah that was amazing I was
when you mentioned meditation I was
going to have you do it at the end so
I'm even gonna clip that just into a
meditation by itself for everyone to
start yeah and I just want to say you
know that I recommend the full
meditation as Dawson teaches it but I've
been teaching this to all of my students
and it um it's great in and of itself
and and what what what Bruce Lipton was
saying is when you raise your vibration
into a state of high energy
then your immune system is functioning
totally your immune system works fully
when you're relaxed when you're calm
your immune system will actually uh if
you're really sick what a little do
it'll basically stop you from doing
everything else it'll take all the
energy from your extremities which is
why when you have the flu off and you're
going like I don't want to get out of
bed I can't even walk to the bathroom
because it's doing its job to fight off
the bacteria or the viruses that you're
dealing with in your life so you want to
give it the greatest strength it can
have by not being in fight or flight and
way number six the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is combat
negative energy with Rhonda Byrne Eric
is asking on Instagram how do we combat
negative energy that we are forced to
interact with
if you're feeling really really really
really really with Derek
really good
any negative energy wouldn't come into
your experience if you could keep your
frequency up really high and be feeling
really happy and really good
but the that so that's just one thing
but the other thing is is that I would
just welcome that negative energy
because if you welcome the negative
energy
you completely disempower it so and I've
explained the welcoming process several
times welcoming just means you're not
resisting it and right at the moment I
can feel you're resisting it right and
how you know you're resisting something
is when you say I don't want that okay
so when you say I don't want that that's
your cue you're resisting it and when
you say I don't want that it will stay
because resistance will will keep it
there and also Law of Attraction doesn't
understand the word don't or no or if
negative doesn't exist for Law of
Attraction So when you say I don't want
this Law of Attraction here's I want
this you know I want this negative
energy I want this negative energy
um so that's the first thing and the
second thing is is to welcome it and to
really so welcoming is just to allow it
to be there just it is as it is not
trying to get rid of it not trying to
change it not trying to fix it because
the more or you can do that then it's
got nothing to stick to and it can't be
in your life
so so if you can just relax with it
and just say oh well it's fine
um
and if it is affecting you then go off
and do the secret shifters you know go
and listen to some music that makes you
feel good go and do something that makes
you feel really really good and uh and
then just whenever like you see I see
that as just such a great opportunity
like all of the things that we see is
tough in life I just see as a gift
because when when you've got negative
energy
what is it they're like Angels that's
Angels giving you giving you an
opportunity to release all the negative
energy in your body they're like they're
like Angels Messengers that that are
here to to show you that you've got
negative energy in your body and you can
release it just by welcoming it and
allowing it to be here so anybody that
gets at you you know
that gives you a charge that irritates
you instead of focusing on them feel the
emotion that you have inside of you
welcome it oh my gosh and let it go
because then you're just going to get
happier and happier and happier
I think one of my first things in
failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they rejected you but that's
not personal because they didn't meet me
in person but what if they had me right
so that's the first step the first step
is don't take all fear failure I'll give
an example me and you we've reached out
to countless guests to be on our podcast
we say no all the time we're saying all
the time but if I don't hear a no from
the guest directly that's not a no like
someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah then how do
you deal with that type of so I've had
you say this I've said it a couple of
times and I'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how I genuinely
believe failure has feedback feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability to actually tell you what
you need to improve now not to improve
to get their attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah with the results you
want the results you want and don't make
that result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you weren't
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing no they didn't make
a fight they didn't make the finals they
lost and then they realize they need to
get the team and they need to find their
I think they're bringing Dennis Rodman
and then they start bringing in all
these other players that strengthen
whereas if they would have just said oh
we got the best player in the world we
just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am a failure
your personality literally ad is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called the memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on for
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life you need to create
an environment of Excellence excellence
most people's environments are not
excellent the people around you the the
videos that you watch the things that
are on your wall the voices that are in
your head you have these moments that
are bold that are courageous that make
you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life that you
want to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it the faster
you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now here and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of Express that'll help you but if
it's not my channel it's some other
channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling's
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this channel you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him so
be careful who you pick and maybe you
don't like Elon Musk maybe you like
Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or whoever
but the more you're around that person
the more you will start to think like
them so you want to put that as part of
your daily routine that every day
because yesterday was a different day
you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you got the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
[Music]
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels that make you feel that way so
do an audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this that I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs apginini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be
so whether that's a mood board you put
up for yourself whether it's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push a
little harder it inspires you to want to
believe in yourself and more it inspires
you to want to go off and take some kind
of action today the physical environment
matters a lot and you can control that
so think about think about your office
think about your bedroom think about
your car think about where you're
spending significant time and how much
of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that
fighting
I want people to believe in themselves
more and I'm going to work when I see
there was a green arrow show I used to
watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're out fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team uh I I don't see my team
physically that often most people work
from home I could just show up every day
in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
God is up to you but but
you present yourself for yourself not
just for the camera I'm not putting this
on just for the camera I'm putting this
on because it's what I put on this is
for me
I could make a video in my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
this is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because there's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change I want to
explain something to you that not many
people really understand I want to talk
about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now I want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed when you're a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now a
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X-Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
X-Type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X-Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change our thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the Paradigm will kick it out
do you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the Paradigm in the thinking control the
vibration you're in and the vibration
you're in is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here what is fear
is fear something that you should fear
no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe your low on tire air
pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open isn't the signal
in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism okay
develop and how does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or distraction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential Threat
predator or threat at the door it lights
up the fear signals since cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine into your
bloodstream so you either know how to
fight it you run away or you freeze
hoping that the Predator will go away so
when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then all this then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed what if succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I put on social
media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stained stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking the brain is a computer
that's a clear fact and it has the same
functions and and systems as our silicon
conventional computer that people is
watching right now and so here's the
Insight I get a brand new computer I got
out of the store and I push start and it
boots up what does that mean the screen
lights up I said oh great got a brand
new computer let's do a drawing let's do
a story a spreadsheet and say no I can't
do it I say why not you got a brand new
computer you say not until I put
programs in the computer can I use that
computer
and so I say oh and then after I got the
programs and then I can type and I can
interface the computer but I without a
program I can't do anything the human
brain as a computer gets programmed
starting in the last trimester of
pregnancy through age seven because the
brain function is not high enough for
Consciousness most of the time it's a
little lower and I say that's what we
said Theta hypnosis I say why is it
relevant the answer is very important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there's thousands of rules to
be of you know a person in the community
like a an infant can't read the book I
go no the infant brain is actually like
a video recorder it watches the mother
it watches the Father the siblings it
watches the community downloads their
behavior those are the programs
after age seven a child then can work
the computer and do what it wants okay
so I basically say so it started in
utero this is how uh um a mother can
play music uh through her abdominal wall
you know put the speaker there uh and
repeat that music and guess what when
the baby's born she plays that music the
baby instantly knows that music or the
father talks to the baby through the
abdominal wall uh and repeats this and
when the baby is born the moment the
father says something the baby will know
which one the father is because it
already memorized this stuff it
memorizes what the mother eats ah
because of the nutrition coming through
I say how does all this work simple we
talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics and I go so why
is it real if I say then whose blood is
the fetus using and development I go the
mothers so I guess so why is that
irrelevant well if she's having an
emotional response that's chemistry and
I said she's feeling that emotion
whether it's wonderful love or fear and
I go so why is it relevant that blood
with the same chemistry of the mother is
going into the fetus I go why is that
Robin the fetus feels what the mother
feels if the mother is under stress and
the fetus is getting an experience that
life is very difficult up there if the
mother is feeling love and support and
everything then the life is easy for the
fetus it started learning in the last
trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and I go so why is
irrelevant I go
once I get past age seven my
Consciousness can type on the keyboard
so I can program what I want and then
here comes the monkey wrench and the
monkey wrench is this the conscious mind
which types can think and you go so what
I go thinking is inside
you know if I ask you Jennifer I say uh
tell me what you're doing uh you know on
Tuesday yeah and right away you can tell
me but you'd have to think oh Tuesday
what am I doing on Tuesday I say what's
the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought and I say
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore I said oh my God I'm gonna crash
the car because of my Consciousness is
inside
that's when the subconscious when the
conscious is thinking the subconscious
is autopilot and takes over like so why
is it relevant I go now science is
recognized 95 of the day is the average
person's amount of thinking okay so why
is it relevant well if a conscious mind
has your wishes and desires and
subconscious as your programs is your
life coming from your wishes and desires
I go up five percent
95 of your life is whatever the hell the
program you got from that seven years is
going to play and if you've got a
program that's not supporting you then
95 of the day your behavior will not
support you because that program doesn't
encourage you okay uh I always give the
audience the same story for 40 years now
okay and you know the story but I'll
tell your community I guess you have a
friend and you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell you're afraid to go
hey Bill you're just like your dad I
said back away from bill because I know
what Bill's going to say the first thing
I said how can you compare me to my dad
I'm nothing like my dad in the audience
laughs I go that's the most profound
story in the world right now I'll tell
you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad who's the one that doesn't
see it bill
let's go with the control and while he's
thinking the behavior is playing but
because he's not even looking out at his
own behavior he doesn't even see his own
behavior yes so in his mind no I'm not
like my identical but everybody else can
see you behave like you're dead you're
the only one that can't see it and I go
so why is it relevant and the answer is
simply this we are all built we all have
beliefs wishes and desires and then we
have to say how come I'm not manifesting
the world I want how come I'm not as
healthy as I want to be how come not
creating the life I want if my mind is a
Creator and I go it is a Creator but
then I tell you which mind are you
operating from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires 95 a
day the subconscious programs are
automatically playing like what if those
programs are not any good I go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so I very simply I wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today I'm
gonna go find love today I'm gonna get
healthy today I'm gonna get the best job
and then at five o'clock you'll come
home and go uh didn't happen it didn't
happen and I go then what does that
person think because they're like Bill
they go oh everything's against me the
universe against me
this person is responsible that person
is responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires I go no
all day long you were shooting yourself
in the foot with your own behavior and
you didn't even know where the gun was
coming from it was in your own hand and
I say so why is a relevant we have been
programmed to believe that when it
doesn't work we are victims of the
outside when the truth is no 95 of the
day we were playing programs that did
not support us and as a result the end
of the day we didn't get that support
but we didn't see it why subconscious
was below conscious was controlling your
life your conscious mind is I'm going to
be healthy I'm going to fall in love and
I go that's great but that's five
percent of the day yeah but 95 I go I'm
coming from a different program and so
when you look at your life and this is a
beautiful part you can say what are my
programs I just want to help people
right away I'll tell you what your
programs are and you say well how do I
know I was being programmed before I was
born I was programmed from zero to one
can you tell me what program you got
when you were zero no you didn't tell
the program you got a one no can you
tell me the program at two no about
three you might say oh I remember some
things but I say you've been essentially
programmed with no awareness of the
program so you didn't even see the
program and now I say so what is your
program you go
I wasn't there now I give you the answer
and you're ready 95 of your life comes
from the program your life is a printout
of your program look at your life right
now and I'm going to tell you this very
simple the things you like that come
into your life they come in because you
have a program to print them in yeah the
things you want Health relationship good
job your struggle you're working hard
you're putting a lot of effort in I'm
gonna make it happen I'm sweating I'm
going to work hard
why you're working so hard and the
answer is simply this your own program
doesn't support that you're trying to
override the 95 of the day that that
negative program is playing with five
percent effort going oh I want it to be
successful I go yeah and 95 of the day
you got what did you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and very interesting fact is this for
400 years the Jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
I go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say give me a child until it is seven
and I will show you the man
what the hell does that mean the answer
is just as I said science has said the
first seven years you're in Theta
program
that's where you're learning then I said
but we're about the rest you'll have to
go 95 of the rest of your life program
so if I can control the first seven
years I control the rest and that's what
they said give me a child until seven I
will show you the man meaning if you let
me do the first seven years of
programming I will tell you how that
child's life is going to work out
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Bob Proctor motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you're earning
hundred thousand a year because they're
not aware of how to earn a hundred
thousand a month
people aren't alone and lonely because
they enjoy being alone and lonely
they're alone and lonely because they're
not aware of how to build meaningful
relationships
[Music]